I
SPRING'S
HISOWISTY
BUT TRUMP FFERED HISIR S PAST WN
CAID REPCE
LOST TO THE CAE RIED TO
OF GOP
HEAVYWEIGHCLUDING TRUMS
OFF AGAIRGIA., ARELL TE THING
ALSO CO-AI REPUBLICAICKETTS,
GOVERNOR.M GOING TO GET TN A RSL
YESTERDATHE SHOOTERSPORTEDESTO T
PERPETD E RIGHSOME POLITICAL
OPA
ABOUT THESE VIS AND OPLEOFFER SH
>>OLUTELY.
RACISM HAS NO ACCA
AND, OF R
THD KEEP
THGHRAYERS.THIS IS WHERE THEE
BE A HATE CRIMF IT  MOTIVATED, N
THAT WAY ON TOP OF MURDERS. REA
METHAT THIS IS JUST
KIND OF GOALS, TS IS NOT A YOU.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT WHATHIS TRY'
NEW YORK GOVERNOKA
THE BINF THIS
PR
OBTAINED THIS WEAPON L
UYN ASULT 18 O
WE T21. THAT?
>> I HAVEN'TOOHE
HAWH W TALKING ABOUT
EV, T TO BE DOING,
WHAT WE'VE KIND OF D
NEBRASKA, ISOR B T
OPEN UP GOOD OF
CO BETWEEN
ECEHAVIORAL HEALTIALISTS TOORE
INSKA IN 201 BENTIVE, SPECIALLY
MENTAL HEAND
I  THING WE CACUS ON.WAA STUDY T
OF MENTAL HE
THNE THINGN DO MORE ON
N NEBRASKA W
DEDICALIONS OF DOLTO ATTRACTE PT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FIELD BECAUSE
WE HAVE SUCH AE N LEGISLATION
TO PUT TIGHTEROLS, EN
AGLIMITAN THLIT?ST>> WE DON'RES.
FOCUS SHOULD BON
PREVEN RESTRICT
E HERE WITNEEDS TO B
BE MORE
SPOTTING THOSE FOLKS AND GETTI
TH TTHERNOR, LET'SAL
THE REPUBLICAN PTY.
NDATDORSED TO
REPLACE YOU  DEFEATED THE
CAE THATMEENT
DOES THIS SHOW THAT ERTS TO END?
>> WELL, HERE INIDATE THAT PRES
ENDORSED WAS A DEEPL
ID
DI THIS.THE REPUBLICANS  BE AT O
I SUPPT
TRUM THIS  W O
SIDES ND OF THE DAY THINK
CERTAINLY TRUE HERE INTATES,
HE DAY, NEBRASKA L END
STATE. N THEY  FOR THE
S JUST ABOUT NEBRAOING TO TR
EEK, JUSLI
MIKE TOCAMPAIGN FORIK.
NG
TRP-
ELECTION.ULD ITE  JSLIKEN MP AF
ICAN
GOVERNORS ASSOCIN, IPROF THESE ?
>>EL TRYFOCUS ON
AND WHAT PRESIDENTR
T
CO-CHAIR OF THE
REPUBLICANOV
CLEAWENCION, WE'VE BEE
BRIAN KEMP IA GREAT INCUA FANTA
WE'REXCITED TO SUPPORT HIM
THAT'S ONE ORE
GO GEOIA I THINK
KERM
AND I THIN'LL BE ABL
BEAT TRACY ABRAMS.
A GREA
>>TRU ASKED TH
THE FORMER IDENT,
TO STA PRIMARY IN
YOUR HOME STATE OF NSK REF HE -H
LAK HIM LAUMAND  GE
D HIM TOTAY  THE
PRIMARY RACE.
OF TU AND
N'T CONTROL.
FORT
ANNOUNCED HE'SOROUG
MA ITHLVANIA
RACE.
W KG TO
TURNHEN
THATLATURE.
PARTCAN'HEO- RGAWOULSUPPORT HIM
THAT THE REPUBLICAN NOMINEES, TD
ON WHERE WE THIN BE EFFECTIVE.
WE CAN WIN, NDIDATHOS N RACES WI
ELECTED IN PNSO  A RE.
HE ANOV O NOM>> THAT'S NOT DORH
CANDIDATESANIA.
WHERE WE HAVE ANN SEE
THAT, THE REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS
ASSOCIATION DOESN'T GE
INVOLVWE WAIT UNTIL THE PEOPLE T
BEATE PICK TIRINEEND
EFFECTIVE IN AND THAWECATE OUR R
ISAD OE GO
THINK E'A LOT
THE' MCAN GENERALL
IT'S VERY CEENT TRHA
VERY BIG INFLUENCE ON TH
PU
FANTASTIC WHENWACOULD SEE THE RT
KNOW, AFRICA NT, ASIAICAN
UNEMPLOYMENT.
SO, GREAT LI T EOPERING IN OUROR
TOUR TRY.
HAVE AIN REPUBNSTHHEAS
PRESIDENT, THERE'S A LOT OFFEREP
TRCE
WERE SO . >> BEFU E S POLICIES
ON ABOOE
HAVE A SO-CALLED TRIGGERN S BUTT
PASS DID
EXCEAPE OR, CAYOU O YO STATEASKA
SHOULD REQUIRE YOUNG GARRY THAT
PREGNANCY TO TERM?
>> SO,EBSTATE.
FE BEGNCE ARBIES, TOO.
CONSTITUTIONAL DECISION, GETS
OVERE OF
YES, THEY'RE S  AKFUEPS TO PROT?
>>
RNED, WILL YOU CL SPECIAL SEAY
VERSUS WADE TURNED, WE  WEO GE
WILL --  WORK WITHUR
SPEAKER OF THEISLATU